hello my name is bradley and this is
some sub a channel on how to survive in
the online jungle today i'm going to
conduct an experiment
i'll buy an old laptop from ebay and try
to restore
the personal data of the guy who sold it
to me even if that guy thinks that he's
already deleted
everything this experiment will show you
how much information you can learn about
anyone by simply examining their old
device
of course there are very effective
methods of protection here and i'm also
going to tell you about those but first
let's go to the one the only this is
ebay
[Music]
so to understand what to look for you
need to know the basic principles of
information recovery when we're talking
about old hard drives when deleting
files the data is not really deleted
at all the space occupied by them rather
is simply marked as free
and until new files overwrite the old
ones it's not really
difficult to restore that old data
moreover the larger the disk the higher
the probability that
one will be able to restore the deleted
files so after going through several
dozen ads
in the uk i came across this the dell
inspirion
6400 with windows 10 pre-installed
according to the characteristics it was
likely that this computer was used for
surfing the internet
and storing photos and text documents
it's not really suitable for much more
when you look at the characteristics
so what we have here is a 120 gigabyte
hard drive the disk space is just about
right and most importantly
it's the kind of ordinary hard drive
that you might expect
if there's any released information it
shouldn't be that hard to get a hold of
it
however just in case there's nothing
there at all we'll order
a second one as a backup i think this
one will do for that
sure it's got a weaker processor and
there's one gigabyte less ram but the
disk has the same space
as 120 gigabytes also the system was
reinstalled here
the listing says a fresh installation of
windows 7.
this means that part of the data has
certainly been overwritten but that's
also quite interesting for our
experiment so i guess let's order it
let's open it
for later
this is actually really funny because
this looks exactly how i pack
christmas presents all right nice we've
got a charging cable here
and another dell spirit
nice looks very worn but i suppose
that's what we want
i bet there's lots of juicy data in this
one the main thing that's important to
understand is that you cannot turn
on purchased laptops from the first ever
reboot
the laptop can start installing updates
indexing files and ultimately
overwriting deleted files
[Music]
keep this in mind in case you
accidentally ironically format your hard
drive
so first i took out the hard drive from
the first laptop and connected it to
another computer via a docking station
there are many programs for data
recovery and they differ in interface
complexity
analysis algorithms the number of
settings and of course the price
i'll not bore you with the details of
how they work because for us the most
important thing is the result
besides i'm not giving you a tutorial on
how to extract private data from someone
else's laptop i'm simply
showing you the risks and demonstrating
how to avoid
certain consequences so my first attempt
to unravel people's secrets will take
place
using the hard drive of the more
powerful laptop with windows 10
installed now i have mixed emotions here
because first of all
the attackers or the potential attackers
wouldn't be very lucky in this
case because i only recovered seven
files and it seems that they're all
located on the computer's desktop
now this wasn't an ideal result for our
experiment but let's have a look at the
catch nevertheless
so we found a shortcut for the microsoft
edge browser
come on who's actually using this as a
shortcut
and five documents judging by the names
these are two cvs a list of keywords
and a presentation about safe sex you've
got a picture
as well and judging by the service file
they'd all been downloaded from the
network
none of these files could actually be
opened as they're deeply corrupted
i even used an online service
recoverytoolbox.com
and it reported that none of the files
actually contain data
by the way as you noticed i partially
hid the names
of the documents i mean there were names
and surnames and i'm
of course going to hide faces and photos
and other important personal data
for obvious reasons
[Music]
i'm going to repeat this again my goal
is to warn you
with the help of an experiment and not
to reveal the private lives of laptop
vendors
although in this case the former owners
knew what they were doing
the computer was clean but
the older model unfortunately turned out
to be a real klondike of information and
this is despite the fact that the seller
stressed that he had reinstalled the
operating system
126 000 files were recovered 65
gigabytes of data
you know i didn't expect this at all
after trying really hard with the first
computer i was worried that we might
have to order another couple of laptops
but as you can see here this is still a
bit of a hellscape
i can sort this out though the program
that restored the information
basically failed to cope with the
structure of the
folders all of the files are in separate
folders with strange names
there are no familiar files like my
documents or recycle bin
the files are rather divided by type
therefore i'm going to sort the folders
firstly by
size in descending order and i'll start
with the largest ones first
the data that i'm interested in might be
hidden there
the largest folder on this computer
takes up 16 gigabytes but it's full of
libraries and service files
if you dig through the names of these
files you can get some additional
information about the owner of the
computer
for example i can find out what
non-standard equipment has been
connected to the computer
and determine what programs were used
see for example this file says that
google chrome was installed as a browser
but i didn't find any traces of firefox
so they probably used google chrome
it's also clear that the owner had the
need to burn cds and dvds
in the older versions of windows as i
recall there were no convenient tools
for this
so that's probably why the nero burn in
rom program appeared in the system
i also found a bunch of drivers for
epson and hp
printers they were all installed
together with the system
and this is indicated by the date of
their creation therefore these files
here really mean nothing
but this actually gave me an idea
instead of ordering the files by name
i'm going to sort them by the date of
creation now this is quite clever
because then the oldest ones will
be related to the original installed
system but the newer ones
will belong to the programs that are
installed by the user manually
this helps me to find traces of flash
player and also programmed for creating
data backups called
ecs todo backup it seems that before the
sale
the owner transferred the data to
another computer
in the folder you see on screen now i
found 204 archive files
in total they take up another 8.5
gigabytes
i tried to unzip some of them but each
time i received messages that the files
were corrupted this folder really didn't
add any clarity here as to who the owner
was
but in the next folder there were 600
files of music and lessons on working
with windows
so this is quite cool i managed to
figure out what was playing in the ears
of the laptop's previous owner
want to listen
[Music]
the playlist turned out to be a curious
mixture of light disco electronic music
in the style of jean-michel jar with
turkish motives too
the auntie's luvian web files were
restored without problem i noticed that
some files actually contained
several tracks at once which sometimes
happens when you digitalize cd disks
this cannot be said about music in mp3
format however for about half of these
files didn't survive
deletion and actually merged into a
random set of sounds
but judging by the names and the
surviving files there's just much more
electronic music here
along with the music in the folder for
some reason there were six torrent files
i copied them into
mtorrent but none of them could be
started the data in them was
unfortunately corrupted
video files also suffered badly those
downloaded from the torrent couldn't be
restored but
i did find a couple of anime clips by
miyazaki which were actually intact
the owner of the computer tried to copy
them from a dvd but
it didn't work out very well the program
left its watermarks right on top of the
video
and this is what the resurrected
futurama series looks like
our policy is if for any reason you're
not completely satisfied
i hate you it's back from the dead now
this is all quite funny but so far it
really hasn't given us much information
about the owner
so i decided to change my search
strategy i'm not going to click
all of the folders in a row as there are
more than 25 000 of them on the disk
but rather to search for individual file
formats
my first really valuable source was
ordinary photos
jpeg files there are almost 6 000 of
them here
now i can't show you all of these photos
in full after all this is someone else's
life but
i think you should know what strangers
can find on your computer
even if you think you've deleted
everything before selling it
so we will take a look at some but don't
worry i'm going to hide all of the faces
and personal details
[Music]
so to begin with i will find all of the
restored photos to do this i'm just
going to type
in a line in search bar dot jpg
so the first images i found are music
album covers
then came the photos clearly taken
during a vacation
the first pictures were taken somewhere
among nature in a park or a forest
and i can't say yet with more certainty
i mean there's no indication of the
shooting location in the exif data of
the images
but judging by the size of the photos
they were taking on a digital camera
and not on a mobile phone but there's
really no
information about this either the images
have a density of 96 dots per
inch therefore most likely they're not
originals but rather versions processed
in a graphic editor
and prepared for viewing on electronic
devices
images from cameras usually have at
least 300 dpi
and this also explains the empty
metadata perhaps a professional botanist
could come to the studio and determine
the location of the shooting for these
pictures but
i can't for sure therefore i'm going to
scroll further to see if i can find out
any
new information so this is the cover of
some
pawn video i guess now this is indicated
by the player icon in the corner of the
frame
the picture wasn't completely restored
as you can see so i don't even have to
censor it
but by the way this doesn't mean that
the former owner actually downloaded
porn the picture could have found its
way onto the hard drive viral website
that was accessed from the computer
itself
but the photos of cats that you can see
here clearly
were saved on purpose
now pictures with friends and parties
don't really provide me with any more
info
you can just see the same faces over and
over again and surely these are family
members or friends of the laptop owner
most likely this guy himself is present
in the pictures
but i think this picture is far more
interesting this is clearly some kind of
mosque and
in the background you can guess that
there's a big city there you've got
hills and skyscrapers now
i already know where this is but let's
just confirm i'm gonna upload this image
to google
and try to find similar ones
bingo google has clearly identified this
place as
top cappy the main palace of the ottoman
empire
now this is one of the most famous sites
of istanbul so
this photo was definitely taken in
turkey right now the search
failed to cope with the next photo
simply assuming that it was a tourist
attraction
we can only say one thing for sure it
was taken from the side of some
boat or ship however we found the photo
of this derry yacht
just a few photos later in addition
someone took a picture of the life boy
on board the ship now the name of the
vessel is written on the top
and the port of registry is written
below
i think that says fetai but
i googled this and this is the name of a
port city in the south west of turkey
now i know exactly where one of the
owners spent
the summer just using this photo
well i didn't even have to google this
photo what resident of london doesn't
recognize saint paul's cathedral
in the center of the picture is a woman
who often has appeared in previous
pictures
and now i know exactly what her name is
where she comes from and where she lives
there was a picture of her passport in
the folder with the photos
i've obviously blurred out the real name
and age of the girl as well as the
numbers on the document
moreover i'm gonna call her by some
fictitious name i don't know
helen will do honestly very sorry that
there's so much information left on this
disc and i really hope that this video
will help you to avoid the same mistakes
that were made out of ignorance
thank god i'm not an intruder neither is
some sub
but how did helen's passport photo end
up in the same place as her vacation
photos
everything's rather simple now i
remember when i was in turkey the guides
warned that it's probably better to
leave your passports in the hotel where
they're safe and instead carry photocops
with you
it seems that the user of the laptop
took a picture of her documents in order
to print several copies
i didn't find any other passports
however i'll assume that helen
was on vacation with her friends not her
family members for instance
so the file gave me a first and a last
name information that helen
now lives in london although she's
originally a german citizen
then i can see the town the height and
the age of our current heroine
now this passport expired in february of
last year so it's no longer possible to
use its number for any fraudulent
purposes but if this computer had got to
the attackers any earlier there could
have been real consequences
admit it do you also keep copies of your
documents on your laptop or your
smartphone
now do you understand why you shouldn't
do it prepare
for unforeseen consequences
[Music]
now another place that helen spent her
summer vacation was suggested by a
picture of a tourist center sign burgos
is a large city on the coast of bulgaria
as it happens
helen spent another vacation in canada i
found a photo of the olympic torch in
vancouver which pointed that out
[Music]
and apparently she was there for some
kind of family celebration
perhaps to visit relatives or friends
you can probably make this out from the
photos right
and then i found out that helen was
interested in books about harry potter
she loves horror and science fiction
this was hinted to me by the covers of
audiobooks that were in the same folder
perhaps she listened to them on vacation
stephen king george martin
now i know which authors i can discuss
if i ever meet helen
god that's quite creepy isn't it and it
also became clear what helen once did
for a living
among the pictures i found screenshots
of correspondence about photos for the
website of some sort of church
unfortunately the quality here is very
poor but the topics and the letters can
still be
made out and by the way the photos of
the wedding ceremony themselves were
also found in
this folder and just below i found
another interesting screenshot
it shows the settings for accessing the
files of some site
that was hosted on dreamhost.com this
confirmed to me the idea that helen was
associated with the development of
websites or perhaps editing maybe she
was a content manager or was responsible
for the photos and pictures i tried
using these axis attributes but
such a site no longer exists
unfortunately i was interested in
following the trailer photos here
these were taken in nightclubs and the
author clearly focused on the person
standing at the dj deck
in the name of one of these images the
word rickster was found
a quick search led me to the page of the
artist with the same name on last fm
music turned out to be quite in the
spirit of those tracks that i
met when i was analyzing music files in
addition i found another screenshot
it had music files that someone had
uploaded to the site all on the same
dreamhost.com usually such screenshots
are added to the reports on
work performed so although i wasn't able
to restore all of the photos the
portrait of helen is acquiring
more and more new features should we
continue to search for images
well jpeg is far from the only image
format
from the popular ones you've got bmp gif
and png
for example these images are clearly
lessons on the basics of web design
they talk about the layout rules they
teach you how to work with epson
printers
it seems that the version about her
being a content manager is becoming more
and more
well realistic by the way the pictures
with the tips for epson farm manager
show a german interface this is an extra
hint
the origin of helen which corroborates
with her passport it's unlikely that an
englishman would watch such lessons in
german
now since we're talking about programs i
decided to run a search for files with
the
dot exe extension these are executable
program files
now when you click on the shortcut in
the menu or on a desktop most often it
launches
a dot exe file here i found programs for
working with pdf files antivirus
programs tools for burning cd and dvd
disks and
here's actually a plugin for flash
animation and here is a program for
uploading files to websites
now this list of programs strengthens my
confidence in what i already know about
helen and i'm also sure that besides
helen another person
also used the computer and how do i know
that
[Music]
well do you remember my video in which i
told you that visited sites leave small
text files on your computer
well these files are called cookies and
they store various information that
helps the site to
basically run better so some sites
actually store the username
in such files look these are helen's
cookies
do you see they start with the name and
after the at symbol
is the name of the site that left this
data
predictably for a traveler she visits
british airways booking.com and car
rental sites
she gets her news from the guardian and
orders dvds on lovefilm.com
but these are files of another user
let's call him
mark look mark
is interested in electronic music and
robotics
he frequents nintendo's websites and
uses file sharing services
mark listens to music through win amp
and records his compositions on sound
upload
he watches videos on youtube and visits
sites with
well questionable content and mark is
also looking for schools on
the website schoolsfinder.direct.gov
please note the first file for helen was
created on october 24
2006 and the first mention of mark
appeared on july 8 2008
a year and a half later since april 2010
only mark has been using the laptop
based on the interests and these dates i
would venture to assume that mark is the
son
or the younger brother of helen at first
he was not allowed to use the computer
and then he sat at it's intern with his
mother
a couple of years later helen got a
brand new toshiba and the old del
well was left to mark this by the way
can explain such a mixture of music
helen might have preferred european
disco with turkish motives while
mark listened and tried to create his
own electronic music
now when i thought about making this
video i was sure that i'd have to put
photos through
google or i'd have to use the services
of data brokers but
with a passport this is just no longer
necessary i just went to facebook and
found
helen by a combination of first name
last name and place of residence
and now i want to ask you a simple
question should i try to get in touch
with helen
tell her the whole story and check how
close i was to the truth
or maybe you shouldn't scare a person
like that suddenly she'll take me for a
fraudster
or some kind of extortionist right but
what do you think
well let me know in the comments and we
can decide together whether we're going
to shoot a continuation of this video
with
ellen involved bill gates alone knows
how much information
could have been extracted from this
laptop after digging a little longer you
can probably find financial documents
restore correspondence and much
much more we've wasted
building this worthless piece of [ __ ]
it's no wonder that stuff like this can
end up on the dark web
and sold it's just that i didn't really
set myself the goal of finding all that
data
and digging out everything i could it
would take many days of work and if i
were a motivated attacker then
of course i do just that but thank god
i'm one of the good guys right
but these simple examples were enough to
show you the danger of letting your
electronic devices fall into the wrong
hands
so look why did i start all this and why
did i do this bloody creepy experiments
in the first place well
to draw your attention to a real serious
threat
do you think only famous people should
be afraid of these sort of things
uh i i i brought up i brought a gift
with me right here
well rather it's the other way around
there's obviously a hunt for famous
laptops and tech so
security specialists are always on hand
with this stuff and by the way a
hollywood millionaire
isn't exactly going to sell their old
laptop on ebay right recover data is a
threat
imagine that it's your computer that
falls into the hands of an attacker
information about your family your
hobbies
and your interests can all be used to
create a scenario for a social
engineering attack to be honest there's
a lot more information in the service
files that can be used to create a cast
of your
digital identity and use it for
fraudulent purposes
for maybe authorization on secure
services or for conducting questionable
banking operations
and in the end your immodest photos that
you thoughtlessly took and then deleted
many years ago can pop up on
popular porn sites do you really need
all of these problems
if not then now i'm going to tell you
how to avoid them
i'm going to leave links to useful
software and services in the description
of this video so go
check them out but look here's some
general advice do not delete files
through the recycle bin
use special programs that overwrite
deleted files with a combination of
random characters one rewrite cycle is
usually enough for ordinary people part
specialists of the us department of
defense overwrite confidential
information
three times and the nsa seven times in a
row
modern versions of windows actually do a
very good job of deleting data
when one chooses to reset to factory
settings and this was demonstrated by my
failure with the first laptop
but there may have been deleted files
hidden on your disk
if you want to get rid of them just use
an old trick first delete
everything except for the operating
system and then fill the disk with bulky
garbage to the limit
for example hundreds of copies of the
same movie
now that's all going to overwrite these
previously deleted files
if you just bought a computer i
recommend creating an encrypted disk for
the data
the files that you store and delete on
it almost impossible to restore
this method will protect you from most
types of attacks but you're still
vulnerable to the attacks on system
files now if you're just choosing a new
computer
give preference to models with ssd not
only do they work faster but it's
much more difficult to recover
information from them the main thing is
to not disable the trim function
and that's basically responsible for the
background cleaning of memory cells
now starting with windows 7 this stuff
is kind of enabled by default but some
programs or drivers
may still disable it and for the most
important piece of advice that i have
you should subscribe to our channel
otherwise my name is bradley
this has been some sub and you are safe
in the online jungle for another day
i'm going to see you in the next video
[Music]
you